can I run a 5k and a full suit of
stormtrooper armor let's find out I need
oxygen at the first mile I came in at
903 a lot faster than I needed to be to
meet my goal of 30 minutes and then
disaster struck disaster my cross PL
unhooked we're just going to run with it
on hook I can't fix it right now at Mile
2 my Pace was still pretty good 9917 but
I was beginning to feel the effects of
the armor and the lack of oxygen in the
helmet I think I need to slow it down a
little I'm low on oxygen starting to see
rings of black a little bit as I kned
the end I thought back to everything led
up to this moment and I knew I had it in
me to finish oh my
gosh of course they put a hill at the
end